we hear things like men are trash men
are the problem all the time what i
don't hear is men saying women are
[ __ ]
that that i don't i don't not not at
this no no no in a public forum not yes
that is not true it depends on the rap
song
you see on social media oh she did this
and she where's men's empowerment
there's women's empowerment empowerment
women negate
men's feelings and i'm not saying
um that it's a good thing or a bad thing
i'm saying that when men become
quote-unquote emotional
they have to do it in a space with maybe
other men
because a lot of the time
if they if men come out in a public
forum
and do it where they're women watching
there are so many women ready to just
like oh look at this guy is soft and
blah blah blah
there are so many women willing to do
that and honestly it's the women asking
the men to be emotionally available like
even when we're advocating for men we
make it about us like we want them to be
emotionally available but not too
emotionally available i've heard so many
women they'll say oh i want a man that
cries in front of me i want a man that's
emotional like oh my god as soon as he
does it oh no not that much don't cry
that much don't be that emotional it's
like what what do women want do you want
them to be emotional or do you want them
to be just hung like strung up and just
hard and not expressing any emotion at
all it's like what you can't have you
can't have
that's why you wanted to stream but have
like stipulations you can cry but not on
these days these days and these days and
not like this this and this you're not
allowing but why am i sure every day no
no i'm not saying
i'm not saying everything you're like
keep going i'm not saying every day but
when a a man when a man is with a woman
he wants to be able to be
free he wants to be able to be free and
have a peace and if a woman is saying
you can do this you can do that but like
this like that that's not being free
that that's not letting them be able to
be themselves so they're not going to
talk about they're just not going to
express it as a whole because you're
putting stipulations on how they can
express themselves so why do i do it
anyways
and that's why i keep telling men and as
mr quote-unquote as misogynistic as it
may sound stop listening to women wait
questions just stop listening to women
they don't even know what they want on a
day-to-day week-to-week math
question for the men in the room if you
were in a relationship all three of you
with your woman
and she was accepting of it all would
you accept what of everything of your
emotions of your your strength of
everything would you feel comfortable to
cry in front of her of course and when
no are you
no no if she's accepting of you because
i understand my understanding of it is
she's allowing me to do these things
however once it is done and i do it it's
gonna switch this there will be a switch
right consequences for my actions the
moment i cry i'll show
that kind of level of vulnerability
you will see the difference so then like
i said stop stop listening to women
because the reason why i said yes is
because i thought okay cool if you're in
a quote-unquote safe space with someone
you're willing to kind of do anything
and everything
but when ish but when ish broke it down
like that it's like yeah well you're
still kind of talking to a woman what am
i not mean it's like yeah
as women we want a guy that can hold it
together
yeah why am i crying yeah yeah for what
it's true it doesn't matter what i'm
saying this one's saying we accept this
something is a bit about accepting we
expect women being the emotional more of
the emotional species
but i understand why am i crying to you
what i'm trying to say is clearly some
men want to be more emotional but they
feel like they can't yeah but i'm saying
give me an example why am i crying why
would i come i don't know and one of
your family members died i was going to
say that i was going to say that because
a family member of mine
my
i'm just going to say it my dad had an
issue when his mother died and his
partner wasn't there for him so his
response was i'm going to go and do x y
and z and that's what he did but it
didn't help the situation so my point is
like as much as women act off emotions
so do men
see that it's not seen as emotion but
you see that that's that context is more
understandable because that's a death
and someone loved ones when women don't
generally only cry on the death it could
just cry because i didn't get a job i
missed the train that woman's thingy
like
the emotion of what men attach them into
crime we can accept because we're crying
over anything and it's cool
but when you're saying when i was
actually about a man crying
a man that is stunned that that's that
you would expect anyone to i would
expect sleep
women women will cry because they went
to work and their boss said something to
them and come home right and be like
something to me
like guys
you know that thing about i'm proud of
him
you watch the videos
my life coach
got onto me because she was confused why
don't you cry
why do you tell me what is going on
comes you don't so you don't cry i do
but i don't cry over like the serious
things i don't cry over like
i didn't cry over what he what all these
things that he did to me i could i can
tell the story like i'm sitting here
with but you know women generally
there's a lot of women that's why
they're
there's many many women that block their
feelings and they cannot cry about the
situations that are painful to them they
turn into men
yeah women
women turn into the men they want to
marry
they become strong and independent
they chase the bag
and they become less emotional
and so they become the men that they
want but do you not feel like sometimes
women are left with no choice
i i think women face the consequences of
their own actions a 20 a 22 year old a
22 year old childless attractive in
shape woman
has a pic has the option to pick a good
man
and if she chooses not to there are
consequences and a lot of the time like
we said earlier on a childless
young fit woman
when faced with a nuclear physicist
right
that is a good man with a good job
we'll say
he got no personality
and then probably go with
i don't know tyrone she didn't even say
that until until she hits her and then
until and that same girl will hit her
30s right and after she let all the bad
boys run through her all through her 20s
go to her 30s and said oh i would pick
that guy that's the one i want
yeah like and
whereas men
whereas men are different and men will
be like
okay
cool what does she offer okay she can be
attractive enough slim enough fit enough
or whatever
he'll take the woman on the as the
checkout no but you know what i always
used to say i remember i should say i'm
back i said men go for what they want
women go for what they can get
that's true
no i thought about it no no wait you
said men go for what they want women go
for what they want men go for what they
can get
that's correct that's correct
did i not say that first
because smearing off you confused me
there for a second i always said my hair
men will go for what they can get women
go for what they want and because men
can accept because men know what they
can get and also they're exercising
their options
men can only exercise the options they
have available to them women
that's not what we said though
what do you mean earlier on in this
conversation we said that men choose
their relationships no no yeah
access
and women give access to sex so that
basically means that the woman might
want the relationship with the man but
because she can't get it all she can do
is give the sex right hoping and having
a baby
but now you're saying that men only get
what they can
do
okay i'll explain men are realistic so
if a man is 5 10 average looking he goes
for an average or slightly below average
looking girl a girl that's a five right
average looking uh maybe even overweight
will sleep with a guy that's a nine and
think she's on his level and then cry
years later because she wasted her time
pining for this guy that doesn't want
her and was out of her league to begin
with and none of her friends were nice
enough and kind enough to be honest with
her and tell her girl you're batting out
of your league why don't you get a guy
on your level not true because i know
men who have gone for women
and they've fallen for them deeply
the woman said i don't care how much
money you have how much dish you have
whatever it is i just don't like you and
the guy is crying
oh that's a small
no
you got all the you got all the
minorities around you real
because
most most men if you say i'm not
interest like there are girls that flirt
with men and lead them on and i see guys
following them around but if a girl says
you know i'm not interested i don't
really want anything to do with you most
men go away and if they don't you can
always call the police and say i'm being
arrested
may not call the police and say woman's
harassing me oh sorry
sorry i say that and this is the point
what we're trying to say so and if a
man's being too much you can always call
the police saying this harass me if a
woman's harassing a man ain't gonna call
the police and say i'm being harassed
i'm around clearly all the minorities
you're around all the minority people
i've been stalked i've dealt with people
that are crying over women i've dealt
with all these different things so how
comes how i just want an explanation why
so people think i'm making it personal
to me but maybe it's because i've just
seen so many abnormalities that maybe
you guys see the difference of so that's
why
generally tend to talk in generalities i
know but and you're you're tending to
talk in the
minority of things so generally there's
a consensus that we can all agree on
generally
but your whole thing is i'mma bring it
back to the people that i know no it's
not about the people that i know it's
about the experiences that i've seen and
it's not just some of them are not do
you think your experiences are of the of
the wider public
um
i don't know because i don't know i mean
we have three girls in here that say
that your experience isn't the norm and
two men so it seems like it's it's just
there's there's three people in here
that are pretty random and two guys and
we're all saying your experiences aren't
oh yeah three including my producer
we're all saying your experiences aren't
the norm and you can't come to the
conclusion that maybe your experiences
aren't the norm
i don't know because
really
you know because from the research that
i've seen in regards to
whatever i've had above and the people
that are around me
i can't give you exactly nothing because
it's easy because when you do that it
kind of it's too general like that's
what you said about the heart attack i
mean that what did you connect it with
and then you read it veins like none of
these women agreed with it you don't
know none of you have had extreme
negotiating period pains do you think do
you think you have a need to be right
no i don't feel like i have a need to be
right no i don't because it kind of
seems like it a little bit
because you don't really admit when
you're wrong like even when we're all
saying oh that's because i have admitted
when i'm wrong okay i just haven't seen
it i'm just telling you what i've what
i've taken from you and yeah
conversation and how i've experienced
you it's like you're always like
you guys are talking that but listen i
know this
and it's like because i'm trying to show
you that as much as you're generalizing
it there is another side of things that
other people do we keep telling you
there's there's exceptions and there's
the rule
like i've said this so many times in the
same conversation so then what happens
to people that
are the exceptions what do you what do
you mean what happens to them like you
mean
like if we we'll be here all day if we
spend
if we talk about every single exception
to every single rule
that's why i said if you give her an
example it's easier that's why
i'm saying an example if you actually
look at this well see this is the thing
i feel like even if i say it you're
gonna say yeah but this yeah but that if
you actually because you read the
statistics on domestic abuse towards men
but did you read the statistics towards
domestic abuse against women and if you
did read it if you did read it you would
turn around and say yeah most of them
are probably lying anyway no no no no no
no
no
one at a time guys i'm telling you i
told you that earlier when
with one-sided domestic abuse 70 of the
time
it is the woman 30 of the time it's
still the men the other the other times
it's they're both abusing each other so
i looked at the the research on both and
i'm trying to tell you when it comes to
coercive control and behavior we've ex
we've established that women are more
emotional so they react to emotions more
than they react to physical and this is
actually a conversation i had been
saying absolutely so but i'm saying what
i'm saying is that is not an excuse like
like that that's not an excuse but
that's actually
unfortunately it's the nature of women
who are abused if you look at women who
are abused they will tell the statistic
actually is a woman probably leaves an
abusive relationship probably after
she's in the she's been abused over 30
times well then we should we should
leave sooner and i'm saying every time
you should every time you should educate
more sorry to cut you i don't i don't
think it's about education i think it's
about choices
it's about it's about like every time i
i feel like you always put it on the men
and i'm saying why don't we take
accountability for our actions if we are
picking these people and we we choose
not to leave but the accountability is
of women to educate other women on the
abuse if i'm saying i've i only left
after the 30th time or the 27th time why
can't i tell the next woman which i have
done and don't get me wrong i look at
these women like why the hell are you
still in the situation when you know
what the [ __ ] is going on excuse my
language when you know what is going on
and
you're you're talking to me about you're
complaining to me about it you're crying
about it you're sending these mad
messages and paragraphs and all of these
things so then don't then you end up
going back to it but clearly it's some
of these women or most of these women is
is to do with emotions you fall for
someone so deeply that you find it so
hard to let go right
that's that's an excuse no no no that is
because you said oh we fall in love so
deeply like we can't like oh no you made
a choice
well see like you see what pearl was
saying and she flipped around early and
you went that's true so which that's the
way you're saying something but she's
agreeing but she's saying if it was a
flip side because when she flips that it
felt like you agreed it was a flip side
and a man is invested as he said young
man had been homeless they tried to love
this woman you know like marriage
breakdowns most women are the ones who
um have the divorce and the manners try
try try try what do the what do other
men say to other men move on so
regardless i know it's sad and this is a
harsh reality there you go it's a harsh
reality but what's pearl's basically
saying once you see those flags there's
only you can only walk from